[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to let's play slender woods
all right this is a game that came out
very recently it's obviously a Slender
game if you couldn't tell by the title
but a lot of people have been requesting
that I play it so I am pretty interested
oh what done huh sound I don't know I'll
leave it up and I'll crank it down
later all right anyway so apparently
this game has a particular story to it
whereas the other ones were just aimless
um wandering in the woods for Pages this
one actually has a legitimate story
which I'm kind of interested in I've
never encountered one I think the game
called slender arrival which is coming
out later this year or early next year
made by the same guy who made slender
the8 pages is actually going to have a
story as well but so far this is the
first one to do that I mean if you count
the original Slenderman game of having a
story I suppose kind of it did but I'm
kind of interested actually very
interested about what could possibly be
in store for me so let's see what
happens in the darkness of Slender men's
words Slender's words SL Slender Man's
words Long Live time though low time
let's hope I don't die cuz it will take
forever oh yes story collecting mode or
story mode not story col never mind life
in the city became unbearable ever since
my wife left me months seemed like years
and my job provided No Satisfaction
whatsoever I didn't even have any
friends in the city I didn't
particularly care either I hated them
all but I remembered my parents old
house in the woods near the city where I
used to live 10 years ago since they
moved away the house was empty but I
still had the keys I decided to move
there for a short time just to get some
fresh air to feel at least something
again I had a feeling that this is what
I needed more than anything in the world
the journey didn't take too long I
reached the house and decided to stay
here for a week everything was going
fine till I heard a strange noises
strange noises outside the house one
night they were driving me
crazy I took a deep breath and decided
go and check it
[Music]
out ah oh the Evil Dead I love that
movie Bruce Campell is my hero all right
so anyway I'm in a wood cabin
or a cabin in the woods rather looks
like there's my flashlight pretty
powerful but drains energy fast okay um
looks like a refrigerator normal kitchen
stuff I'm pretty short all over I got a
text but no time for that ain't nobody
got time for
that all right outside I
go Compass whoa it is wicked dark out
here I guess since it's kind of way out
in the woods
I guess it would make sense that there
wouldn't be any ex extra like outside
lights in
it who hello creature in the woods o
pile of rocks so I'm not exactly sure
what my objective is at the moment got
another
text all right
God I wasn't ready for that I don't feel
good I should probably get back home
okay I'll do
that that wasn't
fun starting this game off with a
bang slendy looks like his old Jolly
self why isn't that light on huh that
wasn't there before no kidding I'm
really trapped something really weird is
going on there's a note wait is that a
note what's he doing here progress SA
it says construction site West so I got
to go to the West all right if you say
so mysterious
note hang on I don't know if like my
battery if turning it off underground
tunnels well it's to the West so I'm
assuming that's where I need to
go
hello
[Music]
slendy Slender Man oh here we go
do that say underground tunnel it's not
construction
site hang on F
mob something I need a key to open this
obviously I knew
that what do you think I am stupid oh
someone really puked here nope oh wait
what's
that construction zone got
it I'm here slendy what did you want
from
me hello pile of dirt oh that's actually
looked kind of familiar oh wo it's light
here no need to waste my flashlights
battery okay but why am I here key
underground tunnels fantastic I've
almost lost all hope I'm runting the
story for anybody fine just to let
somebody know the truth behind what
happened my name is Cody fer fer I'm
lost in these woods and I've been
wandering for hours the middle of the
night the batteries of my flashlight are
running low I can barely see where I'm
going but these aren't the only problems
I have there's something wrong with this
Dark Forest which scares me I feel like
something's lurking in the dark behind
the trees waiting for me thank God I
found this little place where I can rest
I can't find here forever so I'm going
to go now I've seen an entrance to the
underground tunnels nearby maybe the
tunnels will lead me to an exit Okay
works for
me
still kind of creepy out here let me
just double check things around here
little stum boxes oh oh what was that my
camera kind of jerked and I thought I
saw something no probably probably
nothing I'm just a little
jumpy I don't know why I'm in the woods
and Slender's chasing me why am I jumpy
why would anybody be jumpy where I am
okay here we go to the underground
tunnels no looking forward to
this hello yep here we go oh this looks
fantastic phenomenal and it's water
dripping from the ceiling all
right um yeah I guess there's no other
way all right here we
go I don't like this why did I come down
here why did I need to come down
here oh oh I just got
goosebumps go fud this reminds me of
SCP oh no
oh n okay I'm okay I hear Whispers out
like these headphones are really good so
I hear them all around
me uh okay what's this something has
opened good that's good right either and
it maybe I Unleashed something I don't
know that's probably not good
what the hell is that demonic
wasps God I hear things all around me
ah oh oh no oh
no I don't like this place at all this
place is wrong so very wrong okay I'm
guessing I can't go through here oh no I
got it I'm
fine stop that it's like crumbling walls
or something crawling I don't know which
okay here we go
whoa God I am freaking on
edge please remember the new code for
the doors
341 okay 341 easy enough let's go to
it oh man this game is not happy fun
times is it dark yeah it's dark down
here
341 good God
341 god what the hell is
that is there something besides just
Slenderman in this game that would be
zany oh is that
batteries looks like batter's good we'll
swallow your
soul found the Mansion key it's no use
I've been searching all over the tunnels
but haven't found the exit the only
useful thing I found was some batteries
while I was searching I've noticed
something weird in the distance I could
barely see it I'm not sure if it was
real or starting to see hallucinations I
think it looked like a tall human being
but with strange deformed hands it
didn't move when I noticed it but it
disappeared as soon as I tried to come
closer after that I started to have some
kind of headache is this the thing that
was following me in the forest what's
going on here I feel like I'm losing my
mind I've heard that there's a mansion
in this area maybe I can find someone in
there or the working phone at least I I
just don't feel safe
anymore okay good how do
I oh
no no I'm getting out of here oh F this
so hard
sprinting no not
left no a no God damn it oh God
you [__]
a how was I supposed to get away what
was I supposed to
do a a come on I'm all the way back here
really oh this bull okay I know the code
unless it's
changed it's probably changed oh god oh
I get it I need to go open the let me go
this way see if the door is open I
probably shouldn't Sprint like at all
let's just try it it may not be the same
I don't
[Music]
know yes it's the same okay I'm good I'm
good we're doing okay just got to get
the Mansion key and then get the fudge
out of here get the poop out of here
Mansion key blah blah blah
oh okay I don't know what to do if he's
following me okay just don't just save
my Sprint I guess I don't know I don't
know what else I can do
ah no not fair not fair oh oh God oh God
oh God what do I do what do I do
seriously what the f do I
do holy
crap he's freaking everywhere okay if I
go this way right this still gets me
there I think oh crap I don't even
remember which way I
went oh God oh God oh God oh God
ah give me give me give me give me give
me give me give
me oh God get me out of here please save
my progress I feel like I'm getting sick
save my progress please how do I save
how do I save F5 maybe okay how do I get
out of
that okay F5 I don't know I don't think
it can I don't think I can manually save
I think I got to go right or something I
don't know construction site was over
there I don't know where the freaking
Mansion is what is this Richardson
Sawmill okay I can't go in there God
he's out here he's what the
hell
God oh no no don't put me back in the oh
don't put me back down there God damn it
I'm here
God all right God that sucks what am I
what was I supposed to do he just po up
out of
nowhere I mean I didn't see him I didn't
even see static he was just
there all right whatever let's just go 3
1 easy
enough get it grab it
go this is like F6 saves I don't know
four no that's not right either no
nothing there okay batteries and read
the note and get out of here a
all right I'm pretty sure he's just
going to pop up over
here
somewhere yep yep yep
yep is fudge fudge sickles how long does
he stay there oh he stays a while maybe
if I can get him around this corner ah
gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha okay
I'm okay just get me out of here get me
out of here but I don't know what to do
after I get I mean what there's no save
there's no
save there's no save there's no save
there's no saving all right I feel like
I'm getting sick I know I know I'm just
going to
go and I'm going to go past the
construction site maybe the mansion's up
here
fudge fudge fudge he's going to get me
he's going to get me I don't know how
but he's just going to get
[Music]
me freaking out this way I don't know
what's that what is that is that a
battery I don't need a battery right now
I need to get away from slendy ah
running running oh back of
trash no where are you no stop it stop
with a thumpy thump no thumpy thump I
hear a breathing
God damn it Matthew Mansion this way go
go go go go go go go need a save need a
save need a save oh I Need a Freak
fracking save come on I'm almost there
[__] he he's there the front door give
me give me go go
f oh this is not better is it oh man oh
man this game is good this game is real
good anyway progress saved I'm good so
far so I am exactly out of time so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done oh let me know what you think of
this game in the comments below and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye